das was man in deutschland sieht dass
sich eine ideologie die total zerrissen
aus amerika nach europa überschwappte
sich hier ausbreitet und
richtiggehend kulturkämpfe
ausgelöst hat diese
woge kultur ist in sich rassistisch weil
durch diese critical race theorie
menschen in hautfarben
eingestuft werden und ihre wertigkeit
der durch ausgelesen werden also ich als
dunkelhäutiger mensch hier in
deutschland bin eben diskriminierte als
sie es sind und sie sind laut diese
theorie ja auch privilegiert man nutzt
diese situation also die geschichte
deutschlands aus und menschen mundtot zu
machen das ist etwas wo wir aufpassen
müssen weil auch unsere kultur unsere
geschichte soll verleugnet werden also
ich höre den ganzen tag immer wieder
dass bestimmte wörter menschen verletzen
würden wo sind diese verletzten menschen